[Musik]
hey leute was klappt jetzt willkommen
beim neuen videos um ehrlich zu sein ich
habe keine ahnung wie dieses video oder
was genau
keine arme bei allen videos weil ich
eigentlich worauf es hinausläuft heute
würde ich einfach mal erzählen was mir
in den sinn kommt weil es einfach
leider gottes wieder so sein muss dass
ich das irgendwie wieder sagen muss ich
habe dass der früher das war
ich hatte das gleiche eigentlich schon
mal durchgemacht und ich kenne es
mittlerweile wieder spät ich bin
ziemlich müde aber mit jetzt einfach
danach dieses video jetzt zu drehen und
es dann einfach hinter mir zu haben weil
ich ist ja es gibt so viel was ich euch
sagen kann und so viel mehr was ich euch
noch sagen könnte es ist einfach durch
mehr ich ich weiß ganz genau dieses
video werden wieder mehrere
hunderttausend menschen hindu ist das
halt ich weiß ich ich kenne ja
mittlerweile die branche viele
interessieren sich für so was kann ich
auch verstehen
deswegen muss ich sehr sehr aufpassen
was ich sage und es fällt mir verdammt
schwer
also viele haben es ja schon vermutet
wie schon gesagt habe ich hatte ja nett
man fragen antworten video gedreht das
bitte lasst nicht einfach in ruhe wird
auf irgendwelche theorien aufzustellen
oder sonstwas einfach mit dieser frage
bist du noch mit einer freundin zusammen
nein leute wir sind nicht mehr zusammen
das kann ich jetzt erst mal so sagen
auch wenn jetzt viele wahrscheinlich
denken wie kann das sein
hat doch so super gepasst um ehrlich zu
sein ich weiß es nicht
und am liebsten hätte ich einfach zu dem
thema nichts gesagt wirklich das ganze
ist jetzt ungefähr schon drei oder vier
wochen her will ich mal sagen sorry dass
ich nicht offen die kamera gucken aber
wieder irgendwie egal ich will einfach
nur erzählen und am liebsten werden
einfach gewesen so wie man fragt halt so
wo ist sie ich habe ja auch die eine
oder andere traurige snapserver gepostet
oder natürlich solche theorien
aber das häuft sich als wirklich zu
krass und ihr müsst euch da auch
verstehen können ich muss jetzt einfach
dazu mal was sagen weil stellt euch vor
ihr werdet wirklich tagtäglich mit
dieser person nicht nur fünf mal
konfrontiert wirklich egal wo ich bin
auf instat die ganze zeit werde ich zu
spenden auf cnet hat das ist ja
praktisch mein beruf oder mein hobby
meine leidenschaft und dieser mensch hat
so oft gezeigt und wird so oft
angesprochen und da kann man natürlich
nicht wirklich damit abschließen und
also ich kann jetzt erst mal folgendes
sagen wir sind nicht mehr zusammen das
ist jetzt erst mal so und ich muss jetzt
einfach für mich davon ausgehen dass es
auch eine endgültige sache ist inwiefern
das endgültig ist
ich will da wirklich gar nichts zu sagen
wirklich gar nichts aber ich brauche das
für mich einfach und ich muss sagen das
ist jetzt einfach so und deswegen bitte
hat auch wie diese ganzen sachen zu
schicken mir fragen zu stellen und so
was alles leute ich habe euch wirklich
alle sehr sehr lief und ich 50 bin
megastolz der mit 600.000 so aber viele
verstehen nicht ich kann ja nicht
600.000 freunde haben so versteht hier
und ich versuche wirklich immer mein
bestes zu geben vielen zu antwort und so
aber manche sachen die haben als in der
öffentlichkeit nichts zu suchen und ich
verstehe nicht warum das so viele nicht
einfach akzeptieren
ich habe ja schon gesagt wie gesagt und
deswegen leute wir sind nicht mehr
zusammen beschert auch mit diesem ganzen
fragen bitte schreiben jetzt auch nicht
tut mir leid für dich so was hilft nicht
weiter ja so und deswegen muss ich
zumindest auch noch kurz sagen warum das
jetzt erstmal so ist weiß ich ganz genau
würde ich ohne spaß jede zwei minuten
nach zu kommen warum es denn so ist auch
wenn ich mich in meinem kopf ein kriege
wieso menschen nicht verstehen dass das
sie ist nichts angeht wird also leute
von meiner seite her kann ich sagen ihr
müsst wissen so in meinem leben hat sich
auch vieles durch youtube veränderst du
vor allem ist in der letzten zeit wieder
es ich bin jetzt umgezogen nach köln
immer wenn man rausgeht es ist einfach
so man wird viel angeschaut
man wird oftmals nach dem foto gefragt
oder so oder leuten rennen 1
hinterher du hast halt es ist in köln
halt auch krasse du hast nicht so mit
privatsphäre wie hier in meinem dorf
vergleichweise zu köln ist es ja doch
ich frage euch jetzt grad wahrscheinlich
was labert er da und ich weiß auch nicht
ob das irgendwie sind was wenn ich das
zusammenschlagen was ihr wirklich nicht
verstehen kann das ist einfach so etwas
schwer für mich ich hoffe das versteht
ihr auch also ganz kurz noch mal dazu
wir wohnten nicht wirklich nah
aneinander wir haben uns nicht wirklich
auf gesehen so dann dieses ganze mit
youtube immer so viel youtube man hat
oder ich hab ich kann ganz ehrlich sagen
ich finde wenn man eine freundin hat
dann ist es ganz klar so sie gehört an
erster stelle so jetzt hab ich aber ich
kann also sagen youtube ist für mich
einfach an erster stelle ich sehe darin
so viel potenzial ich steh in diesem
ganzen social media business tätig so
viel potenzial und es macht mir so
unfassbar spaßig studiert zwar nebenbei
aber dieses studium das kann sich
niemals so auch dieses level stellen wie
wichtig mir halt einfach dieses ganze
was ich mir so hart aufgebaut habe ich
kann mittlerweile sagen das ist mein
traum und ich kann meinen traum
eigentlich schon so in gewisser weise
leben so ich brauche mir keine gedanken
machen und irgendwas und kann einfach
das machen brauchen bockhop du die
nachteile davon sind einfach man kann
irgendwann nicht mehr mit seiner
freundin einfach mal dahin gehen und was
essen ohne das halt ab und zu leistet zu
entkommen
und es gibt halt menschen wird mal sagen
die das locker sehen und es gibt
menschen die damit halt nicht so gut
umgehen könnt ich bin halt voll da drin
so ich leb das einfach jetzt irgendwie
tagtäglich das ist halt einfach eine
andere art von beziehung ich hoffe ihr
könnt das jetzt gras verstehen also ich
weiß nicht wie ich das sagen weil ich
kann die ganzen genauen gründe die gehen
niemanden von euch was an aber das ist
so ein gewisser weg in diese richtung
und er dann ist es halt so eine art von
verschiedenen ansichten verschiedenen
interessen ich schieb es jetzt gerade
wer viel auf youtube youtube hat viele
vorteile auch viele nachteile
aber es gibt natürlich auch noch andere
dinge besser heißt wir jetzt erst mal
halt getrennte wege gehen so auch wenn
es viele von euch bestimmt sehr schade
finde
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich finde es
auch sehr schade ich finde es
wahrscheinlich am meisten schaden von
allen menschen auf dieser welt
wenn das eigentlich normal sein sollte
ich kann euch auch nur noch darum bitten
bitte lasst ihr auch einfach in ruhe
lasst die volle ding machen
sie ist ein super super super super
wirklich ich möchte nicht dass
irgendjemand zu gering geht und sagt ey
wie du bei dir nicht mehr zusammen dass
das seite von youtube ist oder so was
gehört sich nicht und deswegen bitte
lasst ihr einfach kompletten die
täglichen ganz ganz toller mensch und
ich bin ihr wirklich dankbar für einige
zeit die stand wirklich immer hinter mir
egal was war egal was youtube alles an
zeit eingenommen hat und wie oft ich
jedenfalls fort sie musste da so und das
macht halt nicht jeder mit und
eigentlich geht so was euch auch nicht
an aber ich möchte damit einfach
erreichen dass ihr seht dass sie halt
wirklich steckt so lasst sie einfach
bitte komplette raus wundervoller mensch
fertig ich hab's ja auch schon so gesagt
ich weiß nicht ob du das hier zieht aber
wahrscheinlich werden ist alle deine
freunde sehen und es ihr sicherlich
mitteilen
so ist es ja dann leider meistens sehr
viel erzählt und ich bin wirklich so
glücklich mit meinem leben wie es ist
aber es gibt halt auch nachteile
es gehört immer dazu und ich wollte das
ist alles einfach mal sagen
bitte nehmt das locker aufnimmt gelassen
und es soll ja eigentlich auf youtube
und spaß unterhaltung und sowas gleitern
jetzt halt leider auch mal dazu einfach
nur aus dem grund dass ich euch bitte
mich jetzt komplett mit in ruhe zu
lassen und das ist sehr sehr wichtig für
mich weiter hilft mir das überhaupt
nicht weiter es hat sich jetzt alles
super negativ angehört das ganze video
also wirklich nur an die älteren über
18-jährigen von euch und über die eine
oder andere date anfrage über instant
mich sicherlich auch
ja leute bisschen spaß gemacht und ich
wünsche euch auf einen schönen tag und
nimmt gelassen
konzentriert euch wirklich so das kann
ich nur sagen konzentriert euch wirklich
nur auf euch das ist oder was es nur auf
euch aber konzentriert euch viel auf
euch macht das worauf er bock habt das
war ich auch und das war ein bisschen
motivation zum ende leben geht weiter
wir sehen und ich freue mich auf die
zukunft es wird so viel gutes kommen und
man sollte das schöne im leben nicht
vergessen weil man ich lass mir zu viel
arbeite wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder
hart rein versteht das bitte
und wir sehen uns